[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 165 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Marc Morano and this week I am
delighted to be joined by Brian Dorsey
Brian how are you doing awesome hello
mark and hello everyone so Brian I know
this isn't your first time on the
podcast but it is the first time you're
being hosts do you want to tell people a
little about yourself there's nothing
interesting no but I disagree but go
ahead I'm also a DA on Google cloud I
love me some Python trying to learn some
go fly remote control things and on the
cloud side really have just kind of like
trying to pay attention to all the
different ways we have to run stuff
everywhere all the different compute
options we have digging into MSF I think
actually it's entirely your fault that I
got involved with kubernetes oh maybe I
think it was about a week into I mean
joining Google Cloud you were like yes
so I'm teaching at kubernetes workshop
tomorrow
does anyone want to help be like teacher
assistant I was like sure I'll learn
kubernetes overnight more about you than
me so I blame that entirely on you
so yeah this week we have Dustin Ingram
joining us he is going to be talking to
us all about Python so that's going to
be good after that we have a question of
the week where you're gonna be asking me
something fun so we're gonna talk to me
about manipulating images with cloud
functions which should be interesting
but before we do that why don't we get
stuck into our cool things of the week
excellent yes
so my first cool thing of the week is a
blog post on the Google blog called
machine learning can boost the value of
wind energy this is talking about how
Google has been experimenting with using
machine learning to improve the
prediction of the output of wind farms
essentially and unfortunately wind
doesn't blow at a constant rate all the
time so it's very variable nature being
able to predict what sort of output
you're gonna get from it is usually very
variable because that's what you can
tell the power grid that you're having
in advance and that kind of stuff so
they've managed to make significant
improvements actually on prediction of
wind power output over 36 hour ahead of
actual generation okay
and has boosted the value of their wind
energy by roughly 20% so put a link to
the article machine right so you can dig
into exactly what it is they've done
there but it kind of needs stuff for
renewable energy hope there's a lot of
things that would be more valuable if we
knew about them 36 hours in advance yes
if mistakes that I'm about to make 36
hours in advance I would like to know
that that would be great sign me up
that's a service I'm interested in as
well exactly so my thing is compute
engine guest attributes which is kind of
specific but all of our computer
environments and computers in particular
exposed kind of key value pairs about
the machines via this thing called the
metadata service and you can go to the
hostname and instanceid and other kind
of stuff and so you can you can build
scripts that kind of monitor your whole
fleet or tell what's going on all that
sort of stuff and we've just added in
beta the ability to mix your own data in
with that which seems pretty cool cool
so I got another one here as well from
one of my friends up in Japan what about
our sales teams members Samir Hamoudi
who I've worked with previously he wrote
an article for a company that he works
with cold couple couples a Japanese
mobile game company that's very very
well known over in Japan
but they did something really cool in
the open source land they actually
released a open-source driver for cloud
spanner for the laravel PHP framework I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
which is a very popular framework for
PHP the github repo is all in English
you can read that the blog post here is
all in English if you read Japanese you
can read more about it through that but
you can have a look at Samir's summary
there but yes if you're using laravel
and you want to use you want to use
spanner this is actually a really nice
way of doing it nice in more information
from japan about global things soon
chico Avada wrote everything nice blog
post all about different ways to run
Redis on GCP bounty and in case anyone
from other Redis as an in-memory key
value store with a really rich data
types around the values and you see it
just in architectures for so many large
projects he's kind of gone through all
the different ways to run them and pros
and cons about each of them and she's
really nice to see it kind of all in one
place yes very very cool I'll definitely
check that out
awesome well I think it's probably that
time that we go have a chat with Justin
and talk about all the Python things and
pythons
please - stomach growl noises I'm pretty
sure this week I am delighted to say we
are joined by dustin ingram developer
advocate for python to talk to us all
about all the python things dustin how
are you doing today hey Mark I'm doing
great excellent excellent thank you so
much for joining us and I'm gonna
Brian's pretty excited to talk to you -
oh yeah excellent before we get stuck
into all the Python things though Dustin
do you want to tell us a little about
who you are and what you do here at
Google yeah so I'm a developer advocate
here at Google at Google cloud and my
focus is on Python on the Python
community all of our Python users
everything that we do with Python
basically so I've been working with
Python for a really long time and joined
Google about six months ago and just
really loved and working with Python in
the community and cloud and all the
things that overlap they're awesome so
I'm not particularly familiar with
Python it's not something I for whatever
reason just happened to run into so for
those people who aren't familiar with
Python do you want to tell us a little
bit about the language and like what
it's good for and all that kind of fun
stuff that sounds an interpreted
language so that means it's not compiled
like C or something like that it's sort
of every time you run Python it
interprets the language pythons also
dynamically typed so unlike some other
languages you don't have to specify the
types like if this is a string or if
it's an integer or whatever and then
more generally Python is just kind of
like a pretty high-level language it's
super readable so since the very
beginning pythons have a really strong
focus on code readability so a lot of
people like to say that Python is like
runnable pseudo code so it kind of looks
like something new you write that pseudo
code and it's also kind of looks just
like Python so so for that reason people
really like it beginners really like it
cuz it's easy to pick up and learn that
looks very readable folks just like it
when they you know one of you who are
either code I guess so ok great so are
there any particular great like use
cases for Python is there is there
things you would be like this is the
perfect thing to use Python for I'm
totally biased here cuz like I like to
use Python for everything and one of the
really nice things about I think about
python is if you really want to you can
use it for anything
something else that people like to say
about Python is that it's the second
best language for everything so
basically if you want to do it you could
probably do it in Python might not be
the fastest
or easiest 100 percent of the time but
definitely possible to like do pretty
much anything you want
Python is super popular for web
applications so a lot of real big-name
groups run their large services on
Python so like Instagram for example
that's all
pythons all Django and other similar
large-scale things like to use Python
and data signs as well so a lot of folks
do data science and machine learning and
stuff with Python mostly because that
stuff is hard enough as it is so as long
as you can read your code and write like
meaningful code with Python it sort of
helps abstract away some of the more
complex parts of that I guess okay I do
have to have a follow up on this one
though yeah he said almost everything so
what would you not use Python for would
you maybe not recommend people use as a
first choice for so because python is
interpreted that means like we're not
compiling something down to a binary and
it means that it's a little bit slower
to run just the fact that it's
interpreted it makes it slower and so
anything that's like be super
performance heavy probably not great to
use with Python although there's all
sorts of workarounds for making Python
really fast and I'm specifically talking
about the Python interpreter is is
written in C so that's what we call C
Python and that's sort of is a
relatively mediocre slow interpreter
it's kind of designed to work well and
not necessarily for performance
optimizations there are other Python
interpreter so so there's also like pi
pi which is self hosted python and it's
real fast so depending what you want to
do you can kind of make python a little
bit faster but generally you know if
you're doing anything that's really CPU
bound or i/o bound and pythons maybe not
gonna be the best race you might want to
write a little bit of C or a little bit
of rust or something like that I'm
sitting here trying to think of terrible
ideas we can have a whole nother
conversation Lepus interval ideas okay
so let's say you know which actually is
pretty true I am a Python person and
like I'm curious like what can I do in
Google cloud with Python right out of
the bat putting your Python application
your web application on Google cloud is
like one of our number one use cases
here so way back in the day when App
Engine came out which I think was over
10 years ago now yeah it was one of the
very first
platform-as-a-service type things for
Python says of kind of one of the first
places that you could
take a Python web application and deploy
it absolutely it's changed a lot since
then that's still something that a lot
of people come to Google cloud to do
with Python we still have App Engine we
have compute engine as well we have a
pension flex and cloud functions and all
these sort of like play a little bit
different roles but in the end you're
kind of always deploying a Python
application or some help for functions
it's just a function to Google cloud
nice how do you go about like choosing
which platform is a good fit because you
just said like we've got like seven
different things roll the dice I don't
know yeah so we do we have a lot they do
serve different use cases though so
let's start with like the original app
engine the original app engine made a
lot of choices for you about what run
time was available to you like system
level libraries things like that and you
didn't get to really change that too
much we sort of picked a couple you know
like packages put them in the runtime
for you and they were there you could
bundle some extra Python dependencies
it was pretty restrictive and you know
again that was 10 years ago so things
have changed a little bit the new app
engine you want to use that if you kind
of want a consistent base in egde so
it's a bun - under the hood but you want
to be able to install like whatever
dependencies you want anything from pi
PI or anywhere else yeah and if you just
want to you know respond to like web
traffic that's what happened just really
good for cloud functions also kind of
like that you can also sort of write
something that kind of looks like a web
application and cloud functions but that
would just be basically a function that
responds to an HTTP requests so it would
be like a single endpoint in your
application would be a single function
but then if you don't want to do HTTP at
all cloud functions are great for
triggers across all the GCP so like one
really common example is you want to do
something with a file after it's been
uploaded to your storage bucket so the
clock functions is perfect for this
because you can sort of hook into the
events that are happening see you know
every time this file is out of this
bucket like do this thing and then you
just write a little function to Python
they get some information about the
event and you can do whatever and then
beyond that and like the rest of the
platform sort of just add additional
customizability so like flex you know
you can really customize the runtimes
you need to do really specific video
encoding stuff I know some of our
customers do that they use flex because
they can just really you know
Staal exactly the system well the
library is really you know fast
libraries whatever they need to do to do
a really specific task and works well
for that so here's that fun question for
you I'm writing Python and I've decided
App Engine is the way I want to go to
begin with and then I'm writing stuff on
App Engine and I realize maybe I've made
the wrong choice what is the developer
experience look like for each of those
tools is it easy enough for me to shift
or I suppose it just depends what I'm
building or what's what's your thoughts
there that kind of depends on what
you're building and so yeah let's just
talk about the latest like that but the
new App Engine runtime is Python 37
that's the like we're calling it the
idiomatic
you know App Engine standard runtime
moving off of that would be super easy
because there's nothing really like
locking you into that runtime that's
really specific to App Engine right our
getting started example for example a
lot of people to perform iller with
flask flask is a micro framework for web
applications and Python we just tell you
to write a flask app and then you deploy
that to App Engine and that flask I'm
like you can take that anywhere you can
take that to Heroku you can take that
AWS like anywhere you want it's gonna
work the exactly the same way there's
not gonna be anything specific about it
for App Engine so it's pretty portable
okay I have a follow up here you've you
kind of alluded a couple times to
original App Engine or you kind of said
you know things are different little now
so like for Python people who've been
around for a while and like what they
know of App Engine is like when it first
came out you know or they looked at it
six or eight years ago what's changed
what is new App Engine why should I care
if we are we in like App Engine classic
mode is it like original recipe or
something mmm it's like a retro app
engine and then a futuristic App Engine
app shouldn't call it retro App Engine
so the problem is they're both called
App Engine standard ones that Python to
run time once Python three runtime so
the big difference is well One SPY blend
tool once Python three that's a huge win
for a lot of our users so just having a
Python three runtime it's immediately
available is really great and then yeah
Python to App Engine standard we make a
lot of decisions for you like we provide
only a certain set of system libraries
out of the box it's harder impossible to
install other ones if you want to
install your dependencies like Python
dependencies you kind of have to what's
called ven during them into your
application so it's really like copying
the source code including it bundling it
up with your application and deploying
the whole thing I once the new App
Engine runtime is great because you just
specify a file called requirements
text this is a list of packages that are
available on the Python package index
and then when your App Engine instance
gets created we go to PI API we download
the packages we install them into the
instance and then when you're you know
application goes run then it's there so
it removes a whole lot of this like
developer pain about vendor hanging
things and it also makes it easier for
us to install build distributions and
and all that kind of stuff that comes
along with the sort of idiomatic Python
packaging environment here at Google
cloud like we definitely do a lot of
containers especially for workloads in
which may not necessarily fit into that
web paradigm are there any best
practices for writing containers with
Python or anything people should be
aware of it's pretty standard in
idiomatic container stuff so if you're
familiar with docker I mean using Python
with containers is is pretty
straightforward
one thing about Python that is kind of
interesting like it's kind of hard to
ship a Python executable so something
that would not require an interpreter or
something along with it so a lot of
times people are applying Python in
containers like they're installing
Python and then they're writing a Python
app and those two things are kind of
separated there are a lot of like kind
of third-party approaches to unlink
together the runtime and your user code
into like a single thing and then you
can go like install that a computer
users machine but if you're using
containers like Ubuntu ships with Python
in it so it's already there you're just
gonna you know make sure you have the
right version and then go and write your
code okay I'm convinced I want to like
try some Python on GCP like yeah and I'm
a Python developer where do I get
started I really like this about our
documentation right now so this is kind
of a secret like cloud functions under
the hood is just a flask app so we
talked about flats before that's the
microservice web framework under the
hood that's just flask so for App Engine
when we show in our documentation stuff
like that we're just showing you like
really simple examples with flask so if
you want to get started what I would say
is you know go to the flask
documentation and like take their
QuickStart and just like try and get a
flask little web application running on
your machine and then see if you can
take that and bring it to Google Cloud
because it should be really
straightforward right it should just be
take it you add a little bit of
command-line magic to set up the project
and deploy it and then it should just
work so that's what I'd recommend
because I think that kind of shows like
nice path of like taken existing
application and bring that to Google
Cloud like you don't need to write
anything special just for App Engine or
just for cloud functions and the other
fun thing you can do is like you can
take your individual add points of your
function and then try and break that
apart into like micro-services and put
them on cloud functions because then
this is sort of just the same thing and
for someone like me who like has never
really played with Python where should I
go to learn about Python itself one
thing I really love about Python the
community and the documentation is
generally excellent very well maintained
just super easy to follow usually I'm
definitely biased because I've been
looking at the same documentation for a
long time yeah so I would recommend doc
stop python.org is all of the
documentation about specific Python
standard library and runtimes
and then a huge part of python is the
community of libraries that come along
with it so when you install python you
get the python interpreter and your
standard library and then if you want
more you can come to the python package
index and install like less than i look
there's like a hundred and seventy
thousand different projects they all do
different things so you can go and
install something there though all those
things have their own documentation
generally it's pretty good so I would
start with a you know core Python maybe
take a Python course as lots of
community supported like Python 101 type
of things so as a longtime Python user
you know when you were kind of exploring
GCP was there anything that likes
surprised or made you relate actually
surprised either way but I'm kind of
especially like for surprise made you're
really happy like about how people do
things on TCP or how things worked yeah
so it's actually kind of funny because
my background I spent a lot of time
working on Python packaging stuff so
like I'm the maintainer on package index
had work on some of the packaging tools
for installing packages that kind of
thing and when I got hired to be a
developer advocate for Python in the
back of my mind you know everyone has
this like imposter syndrome anything and
back of my mind I was like like do I
really know that much you up like I kind
of know a lot about this like packaging
thing I don't really know that much
about like maybe Python in general and
then when I got hired I realized like
most people's problems are with
packaging stuff so so I was like
pleasantly surprised to find that but
it's not what you want to hear is that
like a surprises our users were having
lots of packaging problems so I
suffer consultant before had not really
used GCP too much used some of the other
services you know I remember when the
original app engine came out and
remembered it being like kinda weird and
all the things that came along with it
and I didn't really actually even know I
guess maybe we hadn't even launched it
yet so maybe that's why I didn't know
but I didn't know that we were gonna get
this like cool new Python 37 a pinch in
runtime mmm and so when I found out that
we had that or we're about to launch it
I was like this is so cool like this is
exactly what it should be that's really
happy to see you can like just install
dependencies all that stuff and that it
solves a lot of those packaging problems
that I had seen people having so I guess
it shouldn't have surprised me that
Google was working on that before I
started but yeah it was a pleasant
surprise for sure
oh no wavelength what's been the most
interesting or let's just say
interesting thing that you've seen
somebody do with Python that's kind of
also caught you by surprise
I remember we had a pike on a couple
years ago I don't remember which one I
was this is maybe like five years ago so
sort of before the time when we had like
nice like object recognition machine
learning algorithms that you know he can
just build a model and plug it into
Python for what his name but this fellow
had basically he was having a problem
with squirrels eating the birdseed in
his backyard so what he done was with
Python he had created this like image
you know video recognition thing that
could pick out a squirrel in an image
and he had like a water gun on a servo
that could like aim some water at the
squirrels and like I remember seeing
that at the time I think it was either
like a talk or maybe a lightning talk at
PyCon and I'm never being like wow it
didn't know you could do all that stuff
with Python it's so much like it's
controlling the motors it's doing the
image recognition and like all this
stuff that's fantastic as far as like
technically challenging or interesting
things people have done with Python I
mentioned before that there's like
alternative interpreters for Python so
pi PI is the self-hosted Python
interpreter I have dug into the source
code of a little bit and it's like
mind-boggling but basically it's Python
hosted on Python it's Python
interpreting other Python code to the
point when a language like self host
itself is pretty interesting and papaya
is not like exactly Python but the point
at which Python started self hosting
itself
was a huge achievement really
technically interesting to see how you
can write Python code to interpret
Python code it goes right down the
rabbit hole basically but yeah that's a
pretty interesting project as well
actually you said something interesting
before you said there's a CF limitation
that's not that fast and a Python
implementation that's way faster yeah
yeah you might be surprised to hear that
so I'm not a Python core developer but I
kind of like pay attention to what's
going on I think the general like
feeling about creating and working on
the Python interpreter is that they're
not really trying to make it super
performance optimized they want it to be
like bug free and they wanted to be able
to add any features to it have it be
readable for the corn developers and so
yeah it doesn't receive a whole lot of
optimization which is fine like I think
that's totally fine pie pie is
interesting because and this is starting
to get a little bit outside of what I
totally know but they do a whole bunch
of just-in-time kind of like it kind of
looks like compiling Python before had
which which was seeing speeds it up
quite significantly I've seen people say
anywhere from like 5 to 10 times faster
when using pi pi but that comes with a
whole bunch of caveats as well so beware
are there any particular events that you
would recommend that people go to either
to learn about Python or get involved
with the Python community yeah
absolutely
so I thought was great I think Naomi
cedar said at one point you know talk
that she was giving so she's like Python
person I thought come for the language
stay for the community so Python has a
really excellent community a lot of
events that happen really kind of like a
grassroots type of thing not a lot of
like corporate Python events I think so
the big one that I've been to a lot that
I really enjoy is PyCon PyCon takes
place once a year usually doubles up so
it was in Cleveland last year we'll be
in Cleveland in May this year and it's
like this year about 3,500 Python uses
descend on the tiny town of Cleveland at
the Convention Center it's just really
great it's like multiple days of talks
there's tutorials there's development
sprints afterwards and it's just a great
event it's really a community oriented
this also is like a huge so Google will
be there we'll have like a huge booth
huge expo hall or like other Python
shops that are hiring or like do
interesting things with
it's a great event that said there are
so many really super excellent small
community Python events too so I just
got back from Pike Caribbean which kind
of sounds a little bit like a joke like
no it sounds fantastic that sounds
awesome
someone had the brilliant idea of
hosting a Python conference in the
Caribbean in February and turns out like
it's not just an excuse to go to the
Caribbean there's a really amazing
conference in the Dominican Republic
this year they just did such a great job
so interesting to see the community
there as well and it's just as strong as
like anywhere and I've traveled all over
and seen all sorts of Python communities
and you know they're just like great
strong like very cohesive communities a
lot of people working really hard and
trying to like mentor each other elevate
each other so Destin before we let you
go is there anything we haven't managed
to ask you that you want to make sure it
gets on the podcast are you going
anywhere doing anything releasing any
content or just something cool that you
want to make sure it gets on here yeah
so gonna be giving a talk at Google
cloud next yes when we talking about
porting your code from Python to to
Python 3 it's kind of like specific
focus on Google cloud so that's
something that I get a lot of questions
about and should be a good talk should
be interesting and will be published
online afterwards as well also be given
a talk at PyCon so it's probably my
favorite place to give a talk so I'll be
there I also think I'm gonna be in
Cleveland for like two weeks just
floating around all of the events and
you know talking to people so really
excited to see Python users there and
talk to them about Google cloud I like
talking about just Python too so that as
well and mostly just excited about those
events fantastic well Dustin thank you
so much for coming and hanging out with
some the podcast and telling us all
about Python thanks mark thanks Brian
excellent thank you so much Dustin for
coming and teaching us about Python in
general and Python on GCP check him out
following on Twitter and all the things
and let's move on to the question of the
week shall we
mmm here we go my question is cloud
functions seem cool we can lick connect
all of the pieces of the Internet
together I think of as kind of like glue
for all of the events and web requests
you might make here and there but are
they only good for lightweight stuff or
can I do things that are a little more
binary oriented like images no like it's
good thing that you asked me about
images actually Brian thank you so much
was that leading enough we'll have you
back on the podcast definitely so this
is cool I found out about this today and
I was actually kind of excited about it
so cloud functions bundles image magic
in with the runtime which is really
handy
that sounds super cool what's image
magic though Oh image magic yes so image
magic is a little binary you probably
have it on one of your distro so if
you're on Linux or you run Mac or if you
one window subsystem for eliminates on
Windows basically it's a command-line
utility for doing just about anything
you could ever think of ever doing to
from resizing cropping blurring putting
together gifs that are animated like
literally if you can pretty much think
about it you could probably do it with
imagemagick that sounds like a challenge
find me something you can't do okay
that's a thing anyway so apparently it
gets bundled with cloud functions just
so the binaries there usually you can
get a nice wrapper library with your
language like node.js has one for
example or if you really want to just
like run convert that's basically the
command lines and pass it through but
you can do pretty much whatever you want
so that we're going to link to a
tutorial that's actually talking about
joining cloud functions with vision API
and image magic to like blur offensive
images yeah it'll take you through some
of the steps that sounds useful but yeah
essentially image magic lives in the
runtime so either you can use a wrapper
directly so you can basically do
whatever you want so yeah if you wanted
to build a dynamic image resizing thing
for like a container bucket and then
spit that out on the other side you
could do that pretty easily too like
there's really kind of no limit in some
ways that's awesome okay
I feel challenged I'm gonna try to hook
that up and see if I can find something
that can't be done yeah I'm always more
on the other side where I'm like I
wonder what the most ridiculous things
somebody has done with imagemagick yeah
okay yeah it's gonna be some really
sweet at us I'm curious exactly
excellent all right well I hope that I
hope that answers the question for you
Brian it did it's amazingly related to
the question I asked that is good
awesome um where are you going what are
you doing are you up to anything
interesting that you want our listeners
to know about uh yeah I think the next
big thing for me I mentioned kind of
interested in all of our compute stuff
and last couple years I've given a talk
about you know how to decide where to
run your code aimed at developers who
were you know we have multiple blue
hexagons for running your different
things from functions app engine
kubernetes VMs the whole deal right we
do so I'm gonna be doing an update and
much better version of that with some
new stuff to talk about next so nice
I will also be it next doing the podcast
we have a little space on the floor Ryan
may show up if I can work them into a
hair I just volunteered him right now ok
I mean excellent I'll be the Game
Developers Conference doing a lot of
things they'll be the Google booth
they'll be I mean giving your
presentation there's lots of
presentations all day Wednesday there's
all sorts of fun things so if you can't
find anything to do with Google Cloud
and GDC and you're really stuck just hit
me up I'm sure I can direct you to the
right place and I will also be
presenting in April at East Coast game
conference talking about open sourcing
games and also talking about OCONUS and
all the other fun things I think that's
it ok awesome
well Brian thank you very much for
joining me on the podcast this week
likewise thank you for every year and
thank you to everyone who listened all
this way yeah and see you all next week
so yeah
[Music]